pourquoi pourquoi tu t'agites
il était là j'ai cru qu'il y avait une
alerte incendie en fait il a fait comme
ça le public
frère je croyais mais qu'est-ce qui
t'arrive je voulais juste les réveiller
mais qui sont très réveillés regardez
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a deux
grévistes là
quels sont vos revendications
syndicales du public
il y a une prière il y a quoi un
problème c'est quoi le bail tout le
monde est agile bonjour comment vous
appelez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Annie une de mes nombreuses
ça va ma chérie d'amour ça va très bien
et la dernière fois tu prends le bus toi
je t'ai vu à l'arrêt du bus sur la tête
de ma mère je ne rigole pas où tu prends
le bus dans le Paris je sais plus quoi
attendre
je l'ai vu prendre le bus
la prochaine fois je te ramène
attention attention
par contre quand je ramène je galoche
[Rires]
Saint-Malo
s'asseoir
tu viens d'où de Compiègne Compiègne
j'adore quel pèlerin région la région
PACA
une
qui toute seule toute seule tu es comme
le riz tu préfères rester toute seule
tu as raison et alors qu'est-ce que tu
fais dans la vie je suis enseignante
un économie de gestion j'ai adoré
sur ma vie c'est ce que j'ai fait ou ça
à Compiègne
c'est important d'avoir peut-être à côté
de son domicile on a un job quoi dans
quel quoi
vas-y pose-moi une question
[Rires]
parlez-moi de la valeur ajoutée la
valeur ajoutée la TVA quoi
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qui t'a qu'est-ce qui t'a
poussé à venir ben j'avais envie de
venir à TPMP
[Applaudissements]
ou bien tu pars à dire
comment ça va pour ton anniversaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dont une soirée jacuzzi
quand on tire à l'endroit et je peux te
dire que la vedette c'était lui c'est
pas vraiment non quoi
c'était vous la star la star du jacuzzi
du plaisir c'est où du plaisir
[Applaudissements]
dis-moi tu enlèvera ton peignoir demain
merci tu es mignon
les techniciens vous avez reçu votre
smartphone les mecs je vais gueuler
t'inquiète pas je m'en occupe chérie je
m'en occupe je m'en occupe qu'est-ce que
tu fais
[Rires]
on a un massage
t'inquiète pas
[Applaudissements]